republicans warning democrats are about
to open the floodgates on the border
that is already seeing a record surge
new video shows about 300 migrants
pushing through the gate
in del rio texas yesterday and now
democrats are working to give amnesty to
millions of illegal immigrants
by adding that saying that has to be
jaipal says it's got to be part of
the deal in this infrastructure bill
because they're saying that immigration
is infrastructure in part senator
lindsey graham
warning that that could lead to quote an
invasion watch this
that will lead to an invasion of illegal
immigration
it will put jet fuel on a system that's
already broken if you give one person
legal status
there will be a run on our border like
you've never seen before
the dumbest idea in the history of the
senate
the history of the white house it will
lead to a breakdown of law and order
beyond what you see today
so harold let me start with you um you
know just what goes through your mind
when you look at that image
of people pushing on the gates right
to get in and then the border patrol
folks said we were really glad that we
had the
extra border patrol folks from florida
and nebraska helping us because it could
have turned into a really tough
situation
um and then eventually it says it
further down the piece
uh they just let them all in
so it makes me think we need a stronger
border security patrol and that we
should not just rely on state militias
and there should rather state
police officers and others coming in two
it makes you realize that part of what
lindsey graham said there is correct if
we don't do
we don't do the first thing here you
could incentivize even more
and three it's it screams again the
hemisph the lack of a hemispheric
uh strategy to how we're going to
address
this challenge combined with border
security first
both beg the question i think democrats
who believe
that we're going to uh get an enemy
first of all the embassy idea is dumb i
wouldn't know i don't know if it's the
dumbest idea the senator the congress
has come out with because
there's a lot of competition but this is
any democrat that votes for something
like this is probably setting him or has
him or herself up for defeat
next november some may like that some
may not think it's bad for the body
politic
but it's just bad policy put aside the
politics finally and i come back to
where i've always been on this
90 miles off our shore there's a
communist nation called cuba we see the
unrest there
i think the unrest there could lead to
something more positive because it's the
people vomiting all of this
you look at honduras nicaragua you look
at mexico
we have a challenge in this region that
we're not going to solve by
remarking on it every night or even
democrats republicans yelling in the
congress every day
get the border done i even argue for
building the wall
and then let's figure out what we do
from an aid standpoint to stabilize this
this hemisphere
we spend trillions of dollars around the
globe stabilizing parts of the world
it's the right thing to do our security
is at stake
how is not spending billions in our own
hemisphere not smart for ourselves our
kids and our grandkids
you know i'm just so struck jesse by
that image of people pushing on the gate
and
one thing that comes to mind is that
there's plenty of areas that are wide
open
that they can just you know go go that
way and go through those the other thing
that occurs to me is it's the only place
you know on the border where that could
be possible can you imagine people
landing in an airport and like rushing
the passport agents that would be
everywhere can you imagine they wouldn't
be able to tell them to take their shoes
off fast enough
but i think this is a very powerful
piece of footage because
it will influence how people see the
biden border crisis because
you're seeing not families you're seeing
adult grown men force themselves
across this barrier with our border
patrol
agents trying to hold the line this is
not
families wading across the rio grande
and surrendering to border patrol
you see the border you see the fence
americans see that
and they see adult males penetrating it
with force
and that is not something that's going
to gain sympathy
in the american people's eyes and then
you hear about biden just let them all
in afterwards and bust them to god knows
where
if he right now continues this policy
we're on pace for 2.3 million
illegals think about how many we're not
catching and
he's basically releasing to 30 to 40
percent of them
into this country and they're not all
from guatemala and mexico
you're getting people from africa from
the middle east from venezuela and
there's
no way we know who these people are dick
durbin even said it we're opening the
borders for political reasons he says
that new voters aka foreign-born
voters in america do not vote for the
republican party and that is the
demographic trend he said
and he's right foreign-born voters vote
two-to-one democrat
and one in ten voters are foreign born
and that trend
is going to continue axios is reported
on this
this is not a conspiracy theory forget
the politics
how can he square this with a pandemic
right now there's a 900
increase in covid cases in the rio
grande sector right now
and so he's now going to say it's
dangerous to post something about a
vaccine on facebook
but it's not dangerous to let in
hundreds of thousands of
unvaccinated migrants into the country
and then bus them to swing states
that's crazy yeah it's a good point and
they want to pass dig in a three and a
half trillion dollar
deal budget deal that would include
pre-k
community college elder care so i mean
you can see
why there's a lot of um interest in
coming here
uh once all of those individuals become
part of the beneficiaries of that kind
of package
a vast entitlement state getting um all
of america essentially addicted to
government handouts that's what they
want to do
senator alex padilla in a quote said
citizenship
is essential infrastructure for
immigrant families well
no amnesty is essential infrastructure
for the democratic party
it is the very foundation in the future
of the democrats retaining power
because right now what we're seeing is
crumbling if they're talking about
amnesty
these left-wing nuts in washington dc
it is the it it's smacks of desperation
that they
know they're going to lose in the
midterms they know they're going to lose
the house
by holding it right now by us the
slightest
majority you know 50 50 split in the
senate they know that they're going to
lose that probably the last shot so
they're just trying to
right to trying to jam anything through
just like these giant
entitlements and because again crime
inflation
this l-o-s-e out
greg yeah the uh you know looking at
that video you saw
people uh you saw an obstacle which
creates friction
so we look at that and go well that
could have been a wall
right that could have been a wall the
only reason why they got in is that they
were let in
but imagine if that i mean this this
kind of is a visual representation of
what could be there and what could have
worked
and and to jesse's point you do see that
this is not
a it's not a cuba situation
it doesn't feel like refugees it feels
like work
like they're coming here to work which
is you know it's great for corporations
they're going to get cheap labor but
what is that going to do to our
unemployment rate at this rate right
you're going to have a lo we already
have people that aren't working
and they're not going to work for the
they're not going to work for the hourly
wages
they're going to work for and that's the
other part of this is that
this is there's a lot of corporations
that really love
love this stuff because it's it's a few
steps away from slave
slave labor it's cheap maybe a few more
than you think
yeah yeah yeah that's a good point hey
sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else